hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering your property
investment questions so
comment anything you like about property
whether it be about hmos rent to rent
lease option agreements packaging and
selling deals finance tax anything at
all comment it below and i'll do my
absolute best to answer your property
investment question also if there's any
challenges you've got maybe you what are
you struggling with what's stopping you
becoming financially free in the next 12
months what's stopping you getting your
first property deal
let me know and i'll try and do my best
to help you with that challenge with
that problem with that question
so just go ahead comment it below all
the all the things you need to know the
questions that you wish you had answers
to go ahead comment and then i will
start answering your questions
we've got um dan stokes
his question is would you do a financial
freedom challenge with me me and my
family have hit hard times since covid
and could really do with your help to
achieve something great dan i appreciate
the question i appreciate you being a
subscriber
can i move into your house for a week
and and do a financial freedom challenge
with you
maybe
i get a lot of people asking me this
question but let me tell you something
you don't need me
to move into your house for you to
become successful in property there are
online resources books cds seminars you
can ask me questions right now and i can
i can help you um i do sometimes move
into people's houses and do crazy stuff
but that's something i'm definitely not
going to be committing to and promising
right now but dan what is it you need
help with specifically let me know
comment in the in the comment box and
i'll do my best to help virtually
daniel natalie says
me and my partner were well on our way
to spending our lives trying to become
debt free but you've convinced us that
that's madness we have 300 000 pounds in
equity and are looking to leave our
lives in london to invest money more
wisely we often ask ourselves if samuel
was in opposition what would he do would
you use the money to buy two to three
houses in cash to brr and keep recycling
question mark um hey daniel great to
have you as a subscriber on the channel
and yeah i think you're right about not
wanting to be debt free most
very successful property entrepreneurs
investors business men and women they
don't actually not have any debts what
they have is they have debt but they
also have cash flow and net
so there might be high net worth
individuals but they're normally high
debt worth individuals as well
so
my advice would probably be yeah use the
money that you've got and and and take
out any equity that you've got if and
only you can invest that into something
that's going to generate you good cash
flow so
for instance you mentioned buying in a
property and then pushing the value up
and refinancing that's absolutely right
rich people recycle their money so
they've met i might have i just i was
just with a guy earlier his name was
thomas atkinson he's 24 years old and he
had a house he just bought a house and
he had a mortgage on it and he was
working full-time as an electrician and
him and his partner were trying to pay
off the mortgage on their house and then
um i spoke with him and he watched some
of my videos and he said actually that's
madness and he actually rather than
trying to pay off the mortgage
he refinanced it and pulled out a bit of
equity that he did have and he ended up
with 50 000 pounds cash with that 50 000
pounds he's gone on to buy four houses
and now he's the money that he's making
from his houses has replaced his income
so he's left his job as an electrician
and now he's working full-time in
property he's packaging deals he's
selling deals he's building his
portfolio because he's learned instead
of trying to pay off his debt he's
learned to leverage debt so the debt
became his friend as opposed to his
enemy that he's trying to pay off so i
hope that helps um
sticky sing i hope i pronounced your
name right sickie sicky stink um been
wanting to get and package some sell
some deals done i feel i know investors
that are interested however they don't
have the time themselves
good for you sticky sync i want to sell
the packages to fund my first rent to
rent deal however i just want to know
what i need legally to ensure i'm 100
compliant thanks for the time and see
you on your crash course hey sticky i
can't wait to meet you at the crash
course super smart
booking and it's free so i'll see you
there and we can talk and get to know
each other hopefully
so in terms of being compliant you're
going to need the right contracts in
place if you're doing a deal with
somebody
i wouldn't sell a deal to an investor
without a contract that's the most
important thing because otherwise you
could say hey here's a property
investment i found it give me three
grand and i'll let you have the deal
and they could pay you three grand but
then in six months time or six years
time they could say oh there's a leaky
roof
you're responsible you're like what
i'm not responsible
well where's the agreement
so you need a contract and the contract
is going to specify exactly what your
service is and exactly what they're
paying for
on top of that there are other things
that really you should have in place as
a deal sorcerer me and my friends have
written a whole book on it if you search
property compliance made easy in amazon
you'll get a compliance but when we go
cover all the ins and outs of insurance
and everything that you might need to
become compliant not just as a deal
sorcerer but also as doing rent to rent
i hope that helps see you soon all right
ethan turner
by the way if you enjoyed the video hit
the like button also i want to know what
your questions are so comment your
questions below
some of my closest friends and family
are joining together to raise capital
for our first property venture we aim to
raise money as fast as possible to get
by to let mortgage with the highest
possible cash flow we have a total of 11
individual investors but some of them
are worried about the large amount of
partners we're going to have since 11 is
a lot i see a lot of benefits as we can
raise capital faster and reduce risk on
each person would you say that working
with a lot of investors would be a good
idea or will it become more hassle than
the benefits give
i wouldn't bring more people than needed
personally every investor is different
but for me
when you've got an investor that's
invested in one of your deals or in a
deal with you
that investor is going to come with a
level of work
conversations contracts i'd rather take
a hundred thousand pounds off one person
than 10 people give me 10 grand
because i'm just dealing with one person
and you say it spreads the risk
but really
you don't want there to be much risk you
want to make sure that the deal
worst case is it
you need to make sure you cannot lose
money
so i wouldn't want to be bringing 11
people onto one deal unless i absolutely
have to i'll be trying to bring on as
few people as possible that's just my
personal opinion
all right asia muhammad i don't think
i'll ever be able to buy a house but i
still watch your videos
the love is real bro the love is deep i
think you will though why don't you take
one of the last persons you know ethan
turner's got 11 investors maybe you can
just take one of those just one of his
11 leaving with 10 and then do a deal
with one of those people um
asia you definitely will man even if you
don't buy a house even if you just
control a house
you know manage it and then and then
push the value up and put to put tenants
in there and benefit from the cash flow
you're 100 will keep watching the videos
brother keep me posted if you need any
help any time hit me up
last question aaron dean
did the uk do an eviction ban like the
usa if yes how did that affect you and
how do you operate with without that
income
uh aaron yes they did do a eviction ban
they said that it's finished now but
they said that you can't evict tenants
for any reason um even if they're not
paying rent during lockdown
personally didn't affect me at all
because my tenants continued to pay rent
because most tenants if they're happy
um
they're not going to stop paying rent
because there's an eviction ban because
then as soon as the eviction ban
finishes
they're gonna get kicked out
it's not that they don't have to pay the
money
it's just that if they don't pay it
there's a period where you can't evict
them because we're in lockdown
i think it's fair i mean some tenants if
they've lost their job and they're being
affected we've covered
and they're in lockdown
that's their home if you're a victim
where they're going to go i i think that
during the crazy circumstances of
lockdown and the pandemic i didn't have
a problem with it
some of my tenants i gave them a reduced
rent while they were there communication
you know i didn't have a problem with it
and none of my students i got a lot of
students
i think i don't know what the percentage
is i think it's like two percent of
tenants just stopped paying their rent
because of the eviction man so
i didn't have a problem with that anyway
i hope you enjoyed this video if you
haven't asked a question yet maybe
you're the person that always watches
the videos but never asks a question
come and ask a question comment below
i'll do my best to answer thank you so
much i'll see you guys next time